noah manoir délégué du syndicat policier
vici non manoir bonjour merci d'être
avec nous alors c'est un peu l'essence
même du terrorisme ont frappé n'importe
quand n'importe où est ce que la france
pouvait vraiment prévenir ce genre de
drame
alors avant d'aborder le faire je tiens
à préciser que désormais je ne suis plus
fonctionne de police en poste je suis
chroniqueur pour le média tv
voilà donc que ceci étant rétablie
comment dire je effectivement je tiens
déjà adressé un message de condoléances
à toutes à toute l'équipe du
commissariat de rambouillet et à la
famille de stéphane et en particulier
qui malheureusement a succombé à ses
blessures
et donc comment dire alors il ya un gros
défaut d'anticipation je dire on se
parle semaine après semaine à chaque
fois qu'on a un attentat effectivement
on leur pose les mêmes questions à la
sab le mans encore et toujours
on a toujours des déplacements
ministériels avec des discours assez
fort des tweets également qui précise
que finalement la france ne laissera
jamais rien passé que l'islamisme sera
vaincu mais la réalité montre autre
chose en fait la réalité montre que les
victimes s'additionnent que finalement
les terroristes nous a envoyé un message
politique qui ait un message extrêmement
clair c'est à dire que même les
policiers au sein des commissariats
c'est attendait c'est un des lieux sans
que tu as he is est protégé par les
forces de l'ordre ne sont pas en
sécurité et donc si les français ne sont
pas en sécurité dans un commissariat ils
ne le sont nulle part ailleurs c'est le
message qu'a voulu nous adresser
l'organisation terroriste qui a sans
doute commandité cet attentat
donc en l'occurrence est ce qu'on aurait
pu l'anticiper
à priori oui parce que ce monsieur n'est
pas un même si les primo-arrivants n'est
n'est pas un nouveau à un nouvel
arrivant sur le territoire national il
arrivé en 2009
vraisemblablement dans la vague de
lampedusa au milieu de centaines de
milliers d'autres
migrants et en l'occurrence même si on
fait pas le lien entre le terrorisme et
l'immigration parce que la majorité des
immigrés et des migrants sont des gens
bien et qui n'ont aucun rapport avec
tout ça on ne peut pas faire l'économie
d'une analyse politique plus profonde à
venise et un nom allez-y je vous en prie
je l'attendais votre question parfait
vous disiez tout à l'heure que c'était
un message clair de l'organisation
terroriste en tout cas ce qu il en est
une qui a commandité cette attente pas
qu'on puisse faire un attentat dans un
commissaire hier on l'a vu un
commissariat un policier visé clairement
c'est l'état français qui est
aujourd'hui lisez bien sûr mais après ça
nous empêche pas d'avoir sans faire de
généralité bien entendu et c'est là une
question d' expertise un regard concret
sur ce qui se passe alors moi je vais
reprendre point par point très
rapidement le discours du premier
ministre
on sait très bien de dire que
géographiquement il ya une magnanville
et et samuel paty et naturellement nous
compatissons à la douleur des familles
des victimes nous ne les oublierons
jamais mais il faut savoir que la
personne qui a assassiné sa mère pattie
était un réfugié
en tout cas je suis d'une famille de
réfugiés tchétchènes il était d'ailleurs
lui même réfugié
celui qui accueille perpétré l'attentât
dans l'église de nice était également
réfugiés tunisiens en provenance
d'italie
la gare saint charles d'accord c'est
exactement le même cas de figure donc à
romans-sur-isère toulouse et j'en passe
donc c'est pas la première fois que ça
se produit le schéma est le même
d'ailleurs je ça fait des années que
j'appelle à la vigilance c'est là que
les policiers et les services de police
au niveau du commandement doivent
appeler à la vigilance sur le mois de
ramadhan et en particulier les journées
de vendredi parce qu'il faut savoir que
là on est à plusieurs dizaines
d'attentats qui ont lieu le vendredi
sert plus de 70% des attentats qui
n'était pas écrit depuis 2016 ont été
perpétrés le vendredi le vendredi 13
novembre
le thalys nathan situation qui a
poignardé des passants
à villejuif récemment romans sur isère
l'attentât devant les locaux de charlie
hebdo samuel paty et j'en passe c'est à
dire que je peux même plus les compter
ils ont lieu le vendredi à chaque fois
et là j'ai enquêté à mon niveau et
aucune consignes de vigilance n'a été
donnée à la proche du mois de ramadan et
10 du vent de dignité vendredi en
particulier d'ailleurs si ce n'est que à
la suite des tags qui ont été perpétrés
la semaine dernière sur les mosquées
on a une note de service qui a appelé à
la vigilance justement autour des lieux
de culte musulmans ce qui est tout à
fait normal mais nettement insuffisant
vous pourrez écouter
je crois que quand on n'a pas les moyens
de tout faire le ministre de l'intérieur
doit fixer des priorités ou qu'est-ce
que la priorité c'est que les policiers
s'occupent des risques d'infection
qu'ovide pour les personnes qui
circulent dans les rues plus ou moins
après le couvre-feu après 19 heures ou
est-ce que c'est d'assurer la sécurité
physique de nos concitoyens y compris
dans les commissariats parce que là on
est plus dans un collège on n'est plus
dans une salle de concert ou dans une
rédaction journalistique on est dans un
commissariat
c'était arrivé à joué-lès-tours c'est
arrivé à la préfecture de police quand
mickaël larpe on a tué quatre policiers
sur place
austère que là l'erreur est humaine la
persévérance et diabolique donc au bout
de la troisième fois on peut se poser la
question du niveau de compétence des
autorités
pour ce qui est de la protection des
français concrètement si on prend à tous
les éléments que vous avez cité qu'est
ce qu'on fait concrètement pour prévenir
ce genre de drame gérald darmanin en
tout cas lui est fermé le renfort cette
semaine de dix mille policiers
supplémentaires
ou comment est-ce que c'est suffisant et
qu'est-ce qu'on en fait ne sait des
mines policiers supplémentaires
écoutez c'est la politique moderne ça
qu'on fait des effets d'annoncé on peut
dire dix mille pourquoi pas vingt mille
ou trente mille de toute façon on est
sur une année électorale le gouvernement
n'aura pas à répondre des décisions qui
sont prises maintenant
donc c'est une politique de long terme
qu'il faut venez c'est à dire que ben
comme ce sont des conflits qui sont
importés de toute façon parce que il
faut savoir que les tunisiens sont un
peuple pacifique
les tunisiens sont l'un des peuples les
plus lus
du maghreb dans les niveaux d'éducation
les plus élevés du monde arabe mais ils
sont frontaliers de la libye et il faut
savoir qu'aujourd'hui la libye est une
région tribale qui est administré en
partie par des anciens militants
d'al-qaïda de la tunisie est un terrain
propice justement pour la diffusion des
idées de ces mouvances vers l'europe
d'ailleurs on n'a pas encore une
revendication de cet acte moi à titre
personnel je ne m'engage pas là-dessus
mais je n'y vois pas la patte de l'état
islamique
je pense que le mode opératoire qui
consiste à attaquer les forces armées
c'est à dire la police et les militaires
c'est plutôt le mode opératoire d'al
qaïda puisque un militant de l'état
islamique aurait plutôt utilisé du
poignard dans une rame de transport en
commun dans un lieu public pour faire un
nombre maximum de victimes
jusqu'à l'arrivée des forces de l'ordre
ça qu'on a un bilan beaucoup plus
important alors qu'al-qaïda transmettre
des messages qui sont de l'ordre du
symbolique c'est à dire de la
déstabilisation des états par justement
des attaques contre les forces armées
n'ont manoir merci d'avoir répondu à nos
questions que vous êtes ancien délégué
syndical à vigy police est désormais
ancien policier et chroniqueur merci à
vous